hey I'm a nice array look he's dancing
and we're gonna be discussing our first
times I always try to do it in the first
embarrassing moment on set I had to wear
these shoes for sit and put them to the
side and some crew guy was like hey
who's man shoes are these because I got
big-ass feet my first embarrassing
moment was where I'm supposed to be in a
fight with the kid and said I actually
hit him because I didn't know that
there's a such thing as stuntman or that
you weren't really supposed to do things
with your eyes do you think no shorts
meant whoa first time you realize you
were famous I still don't know Ava
Duvernay recognized me at her first
movie screaming and I was like I'm on
first big purchase after getting your
first major role I bought a Tesla Sam
what this
that's what swing are you lying no it's
in shock it's your first impression of a
Keith what a steadily fearly is dope
funny dude first impression of ease wow
she's gorgeous
eradicated first heartbreak I was a wee
little lad I guess I broke my own heart
because I liked someone and tried to let
them know that I liked them they were
just they just ran and so my heart broke
I've had my heart broken yet I hope it
never happens first memory that comes to
mind off the set of the photograph the
first thing that we shot is the first
memory that I have the giddiness of
being in the Queens Museum and realizing
that we're like we're doing this this is
happening
yeah the first memory I have is when
we're walking down this like weird
spanish-style corridor thingy and then I
do some arms will yeah there's a
beautiful
[Music]
first big role you nearly landed but it
went to someone else to talk about what
just happened okay I was supposed to be
killed longer and in black panther and
that mother
no I'm just kidding that's probably true
if it was I wouldn't say first big red
carpet event it was actually a blue
carpet event but it was big for me it
was a Critics Choice Awards that I got
invited to and it was cool cuz I was
like damn I'm here I'm at an awards
ceremony
um essence black woman in Hollywood I
was standing behind Sanaa Lathan was my
hero and I almost walked off the carpet
and somebody was like where you going
girl
this is your moment time first celebrity
you ever met was David diverted it's
funny because at the time I didn't even
know she was a celebrity because I don't
know anything and then I saw her and I
was like wow you're so cool it nice and
calm and then there I found out she was
just joint forcible director I don't
know the first liver day I ever met
growing up living in LA you meet people
all the time first thing you do when
you're preparing for a new role read the
damn script first piece of advice you've
given one who's trying to become an
actor do it and watch what he does learn
from him
[Music]